making his eighth start a 5.25 era
in fact he's uh allowed nine earned runs
in his last 25
innings he throws a lot of pitches the
last four starts he's got
five innings one time there's a bullet
hit to left by
ozzy adubo herrera tracks it down on the
edge of the track ozzie's going to try
for two and he'll slide in
mr extra base hit ozzy albee's has a
one-out double and the braves
have a first-inning threat well
freddie's got a chance to
play the run and he unloads on the first
pitch a sinking line drive herrera
knocks it down
braves will have runners at first and
third with one out
and the ball got away now ozzy's going
to try to store the ball dislodged
nab couldn't hang on freddie into second
and the braves take the lead
oh a dangerous head first slide by all
bees
who got absolutely smashed at the plate
i love the aggressive base right now i
do not love that slide
only two to austin riley to miss
two outs first strikeout for more 2-0
pitch and this is hitting the air to
right
backing up on it is harper he's got to
play moving to his left he'll make the
catch
and the side is retired but the braves
score a run
and the braves take the early lead here
in this one one run two hits and one man
was left to board we'll go to the bottom
of the first it's the braves one and the
phillies coming up
outstanding look at those numbers and
even the last two
dynamite 18 strikeouts only three hits
and 14 innings pitched
righties hit 211 against him lefties
217. so not a big difference you saw
that lineup where they stacked the
lefties
where he gets hurt and what nick said
earlier one of his keys are make good
pitches with guys on aboard that big
inning because he has struggled with
runners
in scoring position as morten fires a
fastball past jankowski who asks
if it was a strike ted barrett says yes
and charlie's got his second out
harper's making morton work his 15th
first inning pitch is on the way
and he pulled a string and harper
strikes out and harper swings right over
the top of that hook
and down go to the phillies one two
three a couple of strikeouts for charlie
morton in the bottom of the first inning
hoskins hitting 232 on the season he
does have 21 home runs
1-1 pitch ground ball out to third a
lunge to his left
riley's got it flings it across the
diamond one down
charlie morton mows him down four up
four down to groundouts two strikeouts
bottom dropped out of that morton has
his third strikeout and he is pitching
like he has
everything at his disposal right now he
looks very confident
and very smooth two outs the phillies
threatened here in the second
charlie ready to deal his 42nd pitch of
the ball game
and the one-two swung on and missed got
him with a curveball
strikeout number four for charlie morton
and he's able to bounce back after
giving up back-to-back two-out walks to
herrera and torreyas
two-out base is empty for ozzy albee's
rousey doubled in the first inning
swings at the first pitch and drives one
out towards left field and a humpback
liner falls in front of odual herrera
for a two out
single ozzy once again loaded up on that
back foot
pitch on the way to freddie ground ball
through the ship to the base hitting the
right center field rounding second
heading for third is ozzie
and as he cruises into third base
another base hit for freddy
and the braves keep the ending alive and
now have runners at the corners and the
braves have them loaded hansby swanson a
chance to break a 1 for 18 slide with a
base hit here
swing and a drive he got all of that
baby it's a grand slam
gets a fastball middle and it's all over
it
what a swing from dansby in a huge home
run
first grand slam of his career charlie
morton feeling pretty relaxed right now
with a five-nothing lead
i think i would the way he's been
pitching
here's the o2 curveball got him looking
that was a beauty strike three
always nice to get a grand slam hit for
you
and then start the bottom half of the
ending with the pitcher yeah that's
great isn't it
toward the vacant side all these can't
come up with it
with the umpire running in front of them
and the phillies have a base runner with
one out here in the third
one ball two strikes for jankowski
runner at first
five-nothing braves and a swing and a
miss that's six strikeouts for charlie
morton
that is now seven straight games with
six
strikeouts or better here's the 2-1
pitch
good high in the air to center field
should be playable for guillermo haradia
he's shy of the warning track
and he'll make the catch and there's out
number three and that ends the bottom of
the third inning no runs
one hit no errors one man left we have
played three we had to the top of the
fourth inning who
want to make a statement on this road
trip starting with this series with the
phillies who have been
very rude hosts they have beaten the
braves five out of six times
they've played at citizens bank and now
arcia launches one to left
that ball is gonna go a solo home run
his second of the year second homer has
a brave
that extends the lead to six to nothing
1-0 pitch
swung on and lying towards right harper
on the run to his left he will make the
catch
he has to slide to stop there and a
little bit slow to get up i think that
the ankle probably still is a little bit
of an issue for him but he'll make the
grab the solo home run by arcia
will add to the braves lead as we go to
the bottom of the fourth at six nothing
atlanta
deedy struck out his first time strike
three
gregorius took one inside corner top of
the zone for number seven
i love this pitch right here the
comebacker to a lefty
oh wow double play freddie freeman the
catch steps on the pillow nothing
hoskins could do
about that really solid start for the
braves tonight four very clean innings
out of charlie morton
and the bats have given him plenty of
support bryce harper
has struck out and flied out
and this one on the ground fair ball
freddie takes a peek
and stu surewater harper's retired and
just like that
morton's got his second out of the
inning 3-1
hopped him up on the infield riley
coming in
near the mound he's got it and what a
quick inning
for charlie morton one two three go to
the phillies he set down
six in a row again he has struck out
eight he's gotten this game into the
seventh inning
for atlanta bounced inside the third
base bag down the left field line whoa
arcia didn't see it right away
dee dee's on his way to third and the
throw
is not in time triple
number one for dede oh double herrera
try to get the phillies on the board
here in inning number seven
went out toward left center field that's
gonna be in for an extra base hit it'll
get the first
run of the game home for the fills an
rbi
double for duval herrera so charlie
morton gets a big pat on the back
six plus innings he departs with a
five-run
lead at citizens bank park it's luke
jackson time line drive basically
guess what here comes the throw coming
to the plate is way off line
it's a 6-2 game rbi for
that's his second hit of the day let's
see what luke does
way ahead in the count with runners at
the corners
he did swing and a miss balling in the
dirt jankowski thought he tipped it
and the philly settled for two in the
seventh great job by luke jackson to
preserve a big atlanta lead
and a brave at every base three balls
and a strike
and reilly a bases loaded walk in
atlanta adds on it's seven to two
jesse chavez finished this one off and
earned the braves their sixth win
against the phillies
here in 2021 here it is
on the ground dansby's right there he's
got it how apropos is that
the man that hit the grand slam gets the
final assist
and brian snitker a milestone win
his 400th as the manager of your atlanta
braves
and this critical critical road trip